hi guys I'm Carly Kloss I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to answer your
questions and also play with puppies so
[Music]
it's a real life right now this is a
dream come true this is the best day of
my life this is the best okay question
number one oh there's no cookies in
there trust me already look what is your
favorite and least favorite fashion
trend my favorite fashion trend I would
say I love like high-waisted pants and
kind of like a masculine like suit I
really love I've seen a lot of like
flats and like kitten heels on the
runways and then shoots and I'm a big
fan of that I'm six foot two so I love
like a nice little kitten heel and my
least favorite choice would be probably
like boots eyebrows would you ever
expand code of classy to adult women yes
I would love to so stay tuned I always
see wearing heels I'm 16 and 6 foot how
do I overcome my fear of wearing heels
in public wear your heels proudly and
the fact that you're so tall like
instead of being kind of embarrassed or
shy about that or feeling uncomfortable
like own it I didn't really own my
height until I got older and now I
really love it and I think it's such a a
superpower and
in like a way that only you as a 16 year
old six foot young woman had so own it
own it wear those heels okay
what's something you used to be
criticized for that you improved over
time I used to be about 15 minutes late
everywhere you go and not only five
minutes late and so you know being
timely is something that I'm working on
right fine
okay used to be like 20 minutes okay 20
minutes late on average and now I'm like
five minutes late if you had to wear one
outfit that you already owned for the
rest of your life what would it be and
why I have this amazing Oscar de la
Renta gown that I wore to the Met Ball
it was the last time that I got to spend
time with him and it's this beautiful
gown and it's this and I have it so
maybe I'll I feel like I was one where
that first are you so close with any of
the girls from early on in your fashion
career yes I there are so many friends
of mine who I like one of my friends I
when I was 15 years old backstage at
Calvin Klein's
I walked my very first runway show with
her her name's Tony Goran and Jourdan
Dunn is another dear friend of mine Cara
Delevingne I mean so many of my friends
that I met like really early on in my
career and in their careers and it
really is like a sisterhood like there's
such an amazing kind of network of of
just really fierce women that I've
gotten to know in fashion in modeling in
and in so many other industries that
fashion touches
so many interesting people and so many
that I still am really close to we need
this what are your favorite places in
New York to eat on the budget well first
of all I love to cook if I'm eating on a
budget I love there's this place that's
that's in my neighborhood that I go to
like every other night called lovely day
really delicious
um honey burgers so I'm more like a
french fry and [ __ ] kind of girl but I
do go to Dunkin Donuts like every day
basically so okay you are the cutest
thing when and if you get super stressed
out what are your ways of calming down
and refocusing I'm gonna say this it
doesn't get better than this and to calm
down and refocus and I really like to be
around animals I really like to be in
nature to just kind of like actually
disconnect from Dolphin tech and stress
of daily life and I also really like to
go for a run or to yoga or meditation
but it's hard to beat this what's the
most important lesson that you learned
by the time you turned 21 I think the
most important lesson I learned was the
power of my own voice I think for a long
time especially I started my career
modeling at 15 and I just always as a
model I felt like I was seen and not
heard
and I underestimated the own my own
voice and kind of my opinion sorry I'm
really distracted here um I just think
like everyone has has the power to
influence like those around them anyway
power my voice I would say it's one
thing I really underestimated okay guys
keep it together come on come on now are
they boys or girls old girls quit bit I
have three
stirrers this four of us this is
literally what it's like in my household
how has been made to movement affected
things in the fashion community you know
honestly I think that there's it's been
an awakening in the fashion industry and
in so many industries and it's long
overdue but these conversations are
finally being had both light is being
brought to things that have happened
that are wrong and I think it's
instigating change for the better
certainly in my industry and I think
there's a lot of room for improvement so
what has been your most gratifying
memory since town and cover the
classroom um that's a great question
I've had so many amazing young women
that have been in our code of seniors
program so many scholars past and
present who have been introduced to
coding and computer science through
coded coffee and then gone on to
continue studying whether in school or
in college and I think so many girls
have proudly shown me their college
acceptance to places like Princeton
Harvard MIT I mean these amazing amazing
young women who who learn how to code
with us and it just opens up the whole
world of kind of opportunities and paths
forward careers that they never imagined
otherwise so that makes me really really
proud to see like just this ripple
effect that has in their life okay we
guys come back here come what are you
most excited for people to see an
upcoming season of Project Runway
there's a lot of really interesting
challenges that we do that that like
take into consideration like what's
happening in the fashion industry today
conversations around diversity and
inclusivity social media ecommerce
things that designers have to think
about and these designers in the show I
think do a great job and I'm really
excited for the world to fall in love
with them I feel like this is must be
what it's like to have four children
like
lately come here okay guys last question
let's make it good
ooh what are some of your favorite
things to bake and who do you like to
bake with I really love to bake with my
mom she she's the best my gram taught me
how to bake my Assoc is my favorite
person to bake with but my mom is
amazing and my Aunt Nancy and so every
time I go home we have like a giant
baking session and we bake like cookies
and gooey butter and like the most
delicious decadent not healthy things
and it's wonderful all of these amazing
puppies are available for adoption at
North Shore Animal League
Thank You BuzzFeed for the best
interview of my entire life and check
out more about Kotov classy at our
website bye
[Music]